oh this is I thought was awesome so this
LA City Councilman he's talking about
developing a department that's not like
the cops they don't have weapons but
they're like social workers or people
that understand you know mental
illnesses to go to nonviolent crimes or
not like this right so I'll play this
real quick for you we're looking at non
violent situations where we can send
armed trained people to address those
concerns what we're talking about is
trying to provide the most efficient
service to this city that we can provide
and that's going to take shifting
resources I however believe that if you
have a police department that's focused
on police related matters you have a
quicker response time and I think you'll
get better service when you're talking
about mental health issues like you
referenced earlier who better to be the
first on the scene than a mental health
professional or social worker
individuals that know how to reach and
to communicate with people what do you
guys think I don't know my area of
expertise seems to make sense
kind of makes it it also seems like it
might de-escalate the situation like if
you have a guy come up these cops who
are used to deal with murderers and
criminals and violent you know offenders
don't come up with you know no gun or
nothing like that they're just trying to
de-escalate something and figure out a
solution of the problem make sense more
so than I think a cop who's you know
there to really you know take care of
some dangerous situations well this is
the positive thing I think that the
protests and tourists would not wear now
as Americans we start we start being
more surgical about how we approach law
enforcement problems right and so in
that sense I think it's pretty cool like
now now you're able to see kind of like
how how there's nuance
and there's details you know involved in
what they mean by defunding the police
or rearranging a police department may
boost mental health professionals are
way better in this situation maybe cops
don't want to deal with that they want
they want to stop real crime so that's a
good that's a good intelligent
suggestion again that's why I get
encouraged right now there are these
protests and people are really upset and
things as Americans always do we swing
all the way right all the way left all
the ways to one direction or another but
then you know there's as these things
get opened up for debate we have to get
to the level of detail and legislation
now we start getting a little bit more
most people are sensible and we get a
little bit more detailed now it's like
all right we're not talking we're
getting rid of the whole police
department like Minnesota in Minneapolis
trying to get rid of their [ __ ]
police department the City Council I
mean good luck I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about you want to
get rid of Little Italy get the crime
rate there right now but then also look
at New York who defunded I think a
billion dollars in it they've it's never
been higher crime it's not even that was
not behind police force Blasio hates his
police force so when when when the
[ __ ] police feel like their mayor is
behind them they don't want to [ __ ]
get in trouble they know they get
resentful and they're like this
[ __ ] know the first thing about
policing when she doesn't so what
happens is shootings are up some crazy
amount crime is everywhere and now New
York very quickly goes back to what it
was you know and I was there in the
dangerous 70s when you were so D de
Blasio's you know good luck with that
that's a gamble what's happening to
Atlanta they stopped answering calls the
police saw I don't know what happened in
Baltimore
I think 65% yeah because the police get
terrified Megaten awful the police are
like oh we're the enemy we're public
enemy number one but the majority of
them are good people like oh you want to
eat us like [ __ ] watch what happens well
in Baltimore the majority of them are
black
well the huge part that police
commissioner the police chief is black
the the the other ham is black the
person under his black City Council is
primarily black so you know even in
that City they were like I don't want to
get in trouble for this you know I'm
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]